sous le sou dans le spectacle de gad
elmaleh qui s'appelle la vie normale
retrouvez le sur des les délais un siège
de la ve les cieux
m
alors garde c'était en ami à vous donc
merzak allouache qui vous avait déjà
dirigé dans salut cousin en 95 qui vous
a convaincu de faire un film à partir de
ce personnage de sue fou exactement avec
vous gal elmaleh alain chabat claude
brasseur catherine frot roschdy zem et
arié elmaleh exact si votre frère c'est
mon jeune frère il génial on va les
salles et parfaire lui aussi les biens
pour faire les [ __ ] à cette famille
ils doivent être contents les parents je
dis non non mon père travaille aussi à
la pop elle fait toute la famille toute
la famille belga la machine quand il
chante il est vraiment bien alors le
pitch c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
immigré maghrébins qui s'appelle
chouchou c'est d'habitude ya je le fais
vous le faites je le fait qu'il est vous
le fais tu le fais le fait alors le pit
c'est un jeune immigrés maghrébins qui
s'appelait comment vos servi tout ça
mais je sais pas comment c'est
dakar sénégal maghrébin il s'appelle
souche où il débarque en france déguisé
en réfugiés chiliens
ouais avec le poncho de et puis le
bonnet d'intermittents du spectacle
comme ça ils fui la dictature de
pinochet et il trouve refuge chez un
prêtre qui s'appelle le père léon et qui
jouait par claude brasseur que le
brasseur au curé pour aller le voir
aussi sa volée quelques signes et alors
le sacristain du père léon de claude
brasseur ces roches dizaine absolument
extraordinaire frère jean aussi un
personnage et les croix en bois comme ça
il a des îles à des shorts de scout il
est extraordinaire jeudi on n'a jamais
vu comme ça jamais jamais alors vous
avez dit un truc au sujet de la religion
catholique zanetti le catholicisme est
une religion extrêmement ouverte dans
une église on peut entrer s'asseoir
ce qui est impossible dans une synagogue
ou une mosquée ou un temple bouddhiste
je vous remercie bah c'est vrai nom nous
minorités opprimées les catholiques bien
sûr ce que j'ai dit c'est que en effet
on peut tourner sans problème dans une
église devrait tourner non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un endroit où on peut y
aller en tout cas pour se recueillir et
être tranquille il n'y a aucun problème
c'est plutôt bien je trouvais plutôt
bien merci pour nous donc
ensuite je pars qu'on ait toute
l'histoire mais un jour il va à paris il
rencontre alain chabat que le tour
maubourg pourquoi une pensée le nom
comme ça bah oui parce que en fait moi
ce qui m'éclate et c'était de penser que
chouchou crois aussi que lui aussi il a
un nom à particule l'appelle chouchou de
la place
chabat en aristo français faut le voir
aussi à plein de trucs à voir dans ce
film mais il est extraordinairement
juste
il est où chaque jour extraordinaire à
chaque fois il est juste il regarde même
à quoi ça ressemble minitans auxerre